a lot has happened in the last couple of
weeks first of all i purchased the brand
new
m1 ipad pro and second of all i created
this beautiful design that i shared with
you guys
on my instagram now this project is a
long way from construction
it's probably at least six months away
but with the help of the brand new
m1 ipad i've been able to bring it to
life
so much earlier
what's going on guys my name is david
tomic and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me
on this channel we talk about
architecture and technology
that is exactly what we're doing today
i'm combining my two passions to
showcase something
that i'm really excited to talk to you
about today augmented reality
now for a long time i've been looking at
ways to bring augmented reality into
architecture
especially using archicad as that is my
software of choice
i've finally figured it out now i've
gone through a long road and tested a
lot of different apps some of them which
are complete
and out of trash some of them are pure
viruses
that crash my computer and i had to wipe
a whole bunch of stuff
but i think i've finally landed on
something
that is genuine and something that is
really really
really useful for everybody in the field
so today i'm going to showcase a number
of different things
firstly i'm going to teach you exactly
how to export your project
from archicad and import it into the ar
app second i'm going to talk about the
ar app which is
aki ar k i it is very simple to use
very easy to download and there's not
really much to it so today's video is
going to be relatively short but it's
predominantly going to be me
showing my excitement of how good and
how useful
this can be in today's day life for all
architects
and architecture students so let's get
started by turning around to these two
screens
going over the export process and then
walking you through
the arcy side of things for the
augmented reality
okay so this section of the video is
gonna be incredibly short because it is
very very simple
to export your archicad model in to
the fbx file that is required
so what you want to do is open up the
archicad model that you want to convert
to an
augmented reality model then all you
have to do is open it up in
3d turn on all the layers that you want
to see
and delete everything else you don't
want to see so everything that is
seen in this 3d window will be exported
directly then all we have to do is go
file save as and
change the name and settings down here
so
we want to scroll down to twin motion
2020 fbx
this was my sketch aar test file so
we'll click on that
again go save yes i do want to replace
it
and making sure that these settings in
front of you
right here are exactly the same so there
isn't actually much to change
these are default settings that are
already implemented into archicad
and that's absolutely it once you're
done you hit ok and
let it export once it's exported the
second part is relatively simple
and relatively easy all you need to do
is upload
that file to either onedrive google
drive or
dropbox so for example here i've
uploaded mine to dropbox it's right here
ska dash ar test dot fbx
and that's it all i have to do now is go
over to my ipad
download the ar k i app or the archi app
copy and paste this link directly
into it and that's it now before we jump
into the arky side of things i just want
to let you guys know there's a couple of
links
down below if you want to check them out
first of all there is a discord chat if
you want to join the discord chat
filled with architects and architecture
students all around the world
we share our experiences our ideas and
talk about all these videos
in depth if you join the patreon legends
level member
you'll get all of my archicad tutorial
files that i create on this channel
directly in the discord chat available
for download as soon as my videos go
live there's also some great merch
down below in the description as well
for all architects and
future architects so if you know
somebody that wants to be a future
architect or somebody that
is an architect themselves be sure to
check out the link below
anyway enough of my rambling let's get
it started with this
augmented reality side of the video so
what we want to do is come across
go into our app store find our key
right here on the right hand side it's
by darth design
ltd or experience architecture in ar
as you can see it shows you exactly what
it does and it genuinely does do that
now it does have some paid features
inside of the app which i think are a
bit
over the top especially for this
tutorial but we're not going to showcase
any of that we're just going to stick to
the free features
now let's go into the archi folder it'll
start here in this gallery
and it's all there basic projects that i
have available for you to just play with
if you want to import your own file that
we've just exported
from archicad we're going to go to the
plus sign
it's going to successfully load this
basic project in there
now what we do is come out of that let's
go to our dropbox again
we're going to go copy link copy link
and move back to r key now we want to
tap this
import button down here which if i use
the mouse on
the ipad close that it is this
one on the left hand side then all we
have to do
is come into the paste link and paste
our link directly in there now all we
have to do is click
import preparing for it to download give
it a few seconds depending how big the
file is
and there it is it is imported
in 3d in to our software
now obviously this is all well and good
that it's a nice 3d model and you can
play with it and
you know fumble around and figure out
what's going on
but we want it in ar that's what it's
all about
so let's pop it off that keyboard press
this
magic blue square up the top
move our ipad around and
there it is it is perfectly placed
in front of us as a 3d model so now if i
come closer to you guys
and share this project in full augmented
reality we can start moving around it we
can
start checking out what's going on how
the roof
works how the boundary is how far it's
cut into the ground
what the garage looks like what the
stairs look like
where the bin storage is it is
absolutely incredible what we can do on
the ipad
so quickly and so easily
that's basically it there's nothing
really more to this video it is a very
very simple tutorial
but extremely extremely effective
there is a million and one different
features in the premium version of
archie but i haven't paid for it i
haven't tested it out
i haven't been sponsored by the company
it's just genuinely me
showing my love and appreciation for
architecture and technology
as it progresses right now in 2021
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
i hope you could genuinely share my
excitement about this new technology
and how much it's advanced and how much
it's progressed in such a short period
of time
it has made it so accessible to the
masses and i'm
truly truly grateful that i've stumbled
upon something
so unique if you enjoyed the video make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below and don't forget about the
like button
somehow and truly it does help with the
youtube algorithm it helps more people
see these videos and it helps this
channel grow
so every one of you that smash that like
button thank you so much
it truly is appreciated but like i said
that's all for me today so i'll see you
next monday